[Music]
uh
we have a
retirement community here it's called
the villages remember the villages you
know the villages what did you say do i
remember it like it was the alamo it's
still there yeah sort of so uh we have
this huge retirement community called
the villages kind of near tampa
and uh one was check it out what's up
guys so last week i heard about this
strange town in florida where thousands
of retirees spend the rest of their
lives partying
[Music]
the village is like being on vacation
every day the disney world for retirees
it is like going off to college you see
that let's go check this place out
[Music]
i think maybe you're coming here to
rescue me from the villages a young
person's in my house
why did that happen
oh my god
do you like younger guys do you like
chocolate cake
i like this lady
i like her style man
oh man it's so
awful here everybody's clippy it's like
high school all over again yeah i'm
going to take this off
nice
[ __ ] noise noise this lady is a voice
i'm just experimenting with letting it
go you know i'm saying it's truman's
show here it's like i'm waiting for
the squirrel to cross the street
at 4 45 every day i'm single and
everybody's a couple
don't worry you'll find mr right
this woman
i i swear to god if i roamed a desert
for 40 days and 40 nights i wouldn't be
this thirsty
so if you're attractive and you're
single you think i'm going to be getting
any invitations to these little parties
no the wives don't want you there no
they don't want me there all i heard
about the villages was that like there
were a lot of stds and it's like well
yes we're an elderly population that
doesn't have to worry about getting
pregnant things happen what is it like
being around so many old people here
it's awful they were dead at whatever
job they did before they got here and
now they're dead here and they thought
well once i've landed here it's going to
be okay well how many days can you play
pickleball in a row
i'll go crazy i'll go nuts it's stupid
too really the golf carts are stupid
because you're this old person in this
piece of [ __ ] little thing and cars are
going by you're gonna get killed laura
what are we about to do right now i
gotta be honest with you this woman this
woman is awesome oh yeah laura rules
this woman is the [ __ ] best
to go into sumter landing square
and hold up biden signs
what do you think the reaction's going
to be why now she's still rule though
joseph
oh boy
she were cool up until and then then she
completely lost me
no
president
suck it up villages fighting socks why
sir you think trump was a better man
yeah joe biden uh oh we got a thumbs
down can i can i also say that this is
what's this is what's cringe about this
right
i i found it just as equally cringe when
trump won and everybody wanted to keep
having trump rallies yes and then
everybody kept getting hurt and people
kept getting charged with and it was
like
what is the point of having a rally
after you win an election so you can
hold up a sign saying we won it just
seems [ __ ] dumb
reggie's sense of reality has become
even more out there
whoa i wouldn't even
get hard if i wanted to
uh oh
poor guy see frozen you have a lot in
common with these people
[Laughter]
so very hurtful but is it wrong um
and i thought well [ __ ]
that's why masturbation is so good but
you have it the way you want tibetan
dream yoga is nothing to do
with drugs at all at one point i thought
that was i mean i still do the drugs but
i mean you don't need it it's not
required i mean i do drugs too but
race with my guru and i ended up in
saint petersburg at three o'clock in the
morning at about a hundred florida not
russia 105 miles per hour
after ann came and picked me up from the
institution they put me in that night i
got a call from the police in saint
augustine they'd had a complaint about
reggie he was in a mcdonald's parking
lot
taking everything out of his car
he told him if he threw his phone away
this guy rules i want to hang out with
reggie i want to hang out with reggie so
bad
the police arrested him and put me in a
protective cell and i was buddies with
the police and i thought the guys
driving the ambulance were people i knew
from the villages you're going to be
miserable wherever you live now here
they just will happen to be tan
in funny outfits and so that movie some
kind of heaven they look we look
ridiculous in that movie then why are
you living there i mean i i get it but
you're choosing to live there right
like you move to this place and you're
complaining
but really you know they come here to
find happiness and it doesn't work
because they're still who they are when
they left pittsburgh can i can i may i
ma'am may i comment real quick
they seem happy
yeah it seems again
it could be me or maybe i'm crazy but it
it feels a little bit like you're a
sexless thirsty angry old bitter woman
who's projecting your bitterness onto
all of the old people around you that i
can see from the footage are doing drugs
jet skiing and playing golf and crashing
golf car and getting arrested and
going on [ __ ] drug benders and doing
110 on the highways like
sounds to me like everybody else is
having a pretty [ __ ] in time that's a
really good [ __ ] she's making it sound
like it's an old retirement home we just
saw a guy that was [ __ ] doing drugs
and breaking the law like what are you
talking about this place sounds awesome
actually and it's like every clip is
interspersed with people just like
parasailing and like driving around on
these little weird car like skydiving
and then it just cuts to her going
everyone here is miserable everyone here
[ __ ] hates themselves
and it cuts to other people out dining
out ballroom dancing back to her
seriously look at these people they all
want to kill themselves hobo chili
recipe goes doing 56 on a golf cart with
no governor chip
just [ __ ] rocking here
yeah golf carts that they [ __ ]
removed parts on go faster
no black people whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa lady whoa
whoa whoa holy [ __ ]
go on let's hear this place
that's your out uh yes villages was
renamed to heaven
try to find a black person in the
villages you will not find one well
you're looking at night time
hang on i'm just googling uh
apartment rentals in the villages
villages
you would be a king there by the way you
would be the king of the villages
one two and three bedroom lakeside
village nice
relationship now
how would you feel about a cougar
but why are you living there apparently
you want to live in the in a retirement
home in the south side of chicago yeah
i'm i'm in a relationship right now i am
in a relationship oh cause she was
hitting on him again of course she was
they're always hitting on him
sorry to break your heart no a little
he's got those brown bedroom eyes it's
uh anyway oh god who the [ __ ] thinks
brown eyes are good looking has anybody
ever like i hate when people your
beautiful eyes they're brown
it's literally the color of [ __ ]
first off ouch
what but it's it's true and i'll tell
you who like brown eyes van morrison
yeah i think that song was about anal
sex
oh god
oh i have to write some sorry letters
[Laughter]
a young one this is gonna happen to
everybody okay you're gonna be able to
one day this one's funny and hot he's
got a lot of followers so all right lady
let's [ __ ] lay off a little bit yeah
can you please leave him leave my boy
alone i don't want him to be killed in
the villages she's she's the epitome of
that clip you always play in the
rejoiner with the 30 year old
yeah this is great we're having fun you
didn't bring your wallet that's fine
i'll pay you'll get me next time
me and my two eggs are having a blast
[Laughter]
it's just so
oh man act like you've been there before
lady look how nice he is he's helping
the old vet cross the road
we're here with laura and all right
pause yeah
already calling it
this guy's gonna be my favorite guy the
world war ii vet i can feel it i can
feel it that's the grin the world war
two hat this guy is going to be our
favorite guy rocking the blue blockers
yeah except this guy rules stuart we
should probably start by saying you just
got your
right
uh yes yes i got that on friday do you
enjoy living here in the villages yes i
do
laura held up a biden sign in the town
square yes yes she said she did i said i
was going to shoot her but yeah
[Applause]
what did i just say burst called it
what did i just say he called it i knew
it yeah this guy was gonna be a fun just
sharp old guy i knew i said i was gonna
shoot her
i was just kidding
i may not carry that out i think donald
trump was one of our worst presidents
ever in recorded history
and i think he was the best one in the
last 100 years
[Music]
[ __ ] this guy rules what if they can
do this do me a favor can you uh have
this old guy call the base department i
think that'll be all right let's see
immediately rings you're you're not
you're number one on thecube
sir yes how may we help you i'm the
manager of the baseball player number
576 he would be probably number two yeah
just wait as soon as he takes the phone
out of frozen's hand it just moves up
the queue
finally she got the figure
a brit by the name of glenda jackson she
had a nude scene
and i like how he got rid of can i get
can i give homie props i like how he got
rid of the
beat it speed it i found my favorite
she's getting rejected by world war ii
veterans yes
i thought she had the best pair of
knockers i have ever seen knockers i
love this guy
i do love though yeah he he she
literally got
rejected
by a guy who was probably jumping out of
a plane with major dick
winters and you could tell this woman is
probably despised which is why she
doesn't have a good time in the villa
they probably all hate this woman
okay i didn't mean any of that the place
is great come on down the water's fine
this is the greatest place in the world
to be living whoa whoa kenny loggins is
living there now that's awesome that is
really cool
also uh
again just going back to my point i love
that she just keeps bitching and then it
just keeps cutting to these other people
like i'm having the time of my life this
place [ __ ] i love it
the weather rules i get drunk and ride
golf carts around i mean it really could
be worse the cops don't even waste their
time arresting us what's the point
no place better believe me and you just
the cops won't arrest us because they're
always afraid we're going to die in
custody and they don't want that
liability so they just leave us alone to
look at a nudist camp next door are you
comfortable naked
uh do i look like i'd be comfortable
are you imagining me naked right now
lady i am not i i promise you that i am
not imagining you naked and that's not
even to say look you were probably a
piece of ass 20 years ago 30 but 30
years ago but
let's calm down lady